we know gravity is very weird in several
ways and it's it's also the force we
understand the least in some sense so
it's weird because it's incredibly weak
for example if you take the attractive
force the gravitational force between an
electron and a proton and a hydrogen
atom it's something like a billion
billion billion billion times weaker
than the electromagnetic force that
holds the atom together so gravity is
really incredibly weak and it's weak in
a way we don't understand the other odd
feature of gravity is that unlike the
other forces we know about which we can
understand at microscopic distances with
quantum mechanics for gravity our best
theory comes from Einstein's theory of
general relativity and that explains
gravity at very long distances but we
still don't know how to actually take
Einstein's theory of relativity and
combine it with quantum mechanics to
understanding fundamental gravitational
interactions at very short distances so
the third thing we actually know is that
over the past few decades Astrophysical
observations have told us the vast
majority of the energy density or the
stuff that's actually in the universe
consists of these mysterious components
that we call dark matter and dark energy
and we really don't know what these are
but all we know they all we really know
from these observations is that they
have to interact gravitationally so it
really seems like gravity is at the
heart of some of these major unanswered
questions and physics on a better
understanding of gravity may be able to
help us start to answer some of these
questions